dr. 1549 runway everything Sully Sully
Sully where are you
no one warned us no one said you were
going to lose both engines at a lower
altitude than any jet in history this
was dual engine loss at 2,800 feet
followed by an immediate water landing
with 155 souls on board no one has ever
trained for an incident like that our
job is to investigate how a plane ended
up in the Hudson River all does not a
crash was a forced water landing
simulations show that you could make it
back to the airport not possible I felt
it go my aircraft aircraft I'm gonna
know I did the best I could of course
you did just saved everyone people call
you a hero I don't feel like a hero
there's been too much talking to press
already I'm overwhelmed by all this
attention the left engine was still
operating I didn't get this right i
endangered the lives of all those
passengers I got an a320 diving for the
ribbon here's everything you could have
was more than enough when's your last
drink Atmos Homburg and he had any
troubles at home
this is the captain brace for impact
what
heads down there we'll have people up
that place you were one of them
over 40 years in the air but in the end
I'm going to be judged on 208 seconds
you know thanks most of the rest of us
will never know that's God